hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and
so excited that the candidates
tournament is back we started this
tournament
last year but halfway through had to
stop because of everything going on in
the world but they resumed the
candidates tournament today
will be finished now over the next week
and a half
we will have coverage every single day
that there is
a match going on i'll either pick the
best match or
if there's two of the top players in the
standings i will be covering
that match just to give you a recap of
what's going on so far
before we get into the match today this
tournament the winner plays magnus
carlson for the world championship
later in the year there's eight
competitors these players have been
competing over the last couple years
to get their spot in this tournament so
very difficult to get your spot
in this tournament we play 14 rounds
in this tournament each player will play
each opponents
twice one with the white pieces one with
the black pieces so
without further ado let's go and get
into today's match we have fabiano
caruana playing the white pieces
black being played by mvl so fabiano won
this tournament
last time it was held in 2018
he currently sits tied for third in the
l playing the black pieces
he currently sits in first place has not
lost
through the first seven rounds fabiano
starts this game
with e4 and then we get into the
sicilian with c5 now when these players
mets in the first round of this
tournament
a year ago we saw the rye lopez so we
saw fabiano respond with e5 and then
they got into knight f3
knight c6 bishop here to b5 but now we
have
mbl on the black side and he decides to
go for the
sicilian so c5 a knight f3
upon a d6 and after the exchange here on
d4 and that f6 knight c3
we see the knight dwarf with pawn two a6
a lot of times it's pretty popular for
white to continue here with bishop here
to e3
fabiano goes with what used to be the
main line that's just bishop here two g5
attacking the knight
pawn to e6 just allowing for the queen
to
recapture here on f6 depending on how
white wants to play here
pawn to f4 and then queen to b6 so
getting into potentially the poison pond
here
on b2 and fabiano says yeah let's go
ahead and go down that line so queen to
d2 and then
queen comes down to b2 i do have a
separate video
specifically on the poison pawn in the
night dwarf defense
that's on the website
thechestwebsite.com if you want to check
that out
but the reason it's called poison pond
is white definitely gives up a pawn and
material here on b2
but then the queen is somewhat trapped
now it's not completely trapped it is
difficult for black to really hold on to
the queen but if you play precisely
you're not going to lose your
queen but it also gets your queen
not involved into the game at all and so
white is really able to
attack and control the center of the
board black structure is
pretty cramped in this specific opening
and you can see the queen here on a3
isn't helping
defend or attack the center of the board
so fabiano continues with pawn
to e5 says yeah that's more than enough
for giving up that pawn here on b2
we do see pawn two h6 bishop comes back
here to h4
and then after the exchange right here
knight to d7 attacking his pawn here on
e5
and then knight to e4 and this is
a pretty interesting trap here
if you look at this and say okay this
knight here on d7
came back to attack this pawn here on e5
and white just completely disregarded it
and up until this point fabiano has been
playing
lightning fast not thinking at all a few
seconds here and there
and so there's a reason that he plays
knight to e4 and is not worrying about
this pawn on e5 but it's
i think it's pretty difficult to even
see exactly what the threat is
but if the knight takes here on e5 the
threat
is going to be knight to b5 and yes this
is attacking the queen if you look at
and say well
the pawn can just take that this bishop
here on h4
really poses massive threats because
this is just checkmate here on
d8 so that's really the main threat so
if you kind of look at okay well
we can't let that happen for sure and
just something like a4 since the queen
is under attack that doesn't stop it the
queen could just still come up here
but something like queen 2a5 that does
stop the threat here on d8 but then the
queen just falls so you start to see
that there's
there's not a lot of good moves that
black has here maybe bishop to e7 this
does stop
the bishop from attacking the square
here on d8 but then there's
the queen falls here on a3
but black does have a pretty good move
here
to stop this now it's still a bad play
overall for black that's why
mbl is not going to take here on e5 but
it is interesting to find that the move
for
black is knight to d3
because if the queen takes okay well
then black's
out of out of trouble here that's fine
uh
and if you just take with your pawn here
okay well that now blocks the queen from
attacking this
d8 square and then the knight's gonna
fall here
you could also just take the bishop
which makes sense now the pawn takes
here
uh bishop takes on b5 probably the best
line for white here
check and then after knight 2d7 castle
on the king side now you can see
black is still up a pawn in material but
black's in a really tough spot you can
see the light square bishop
it's not moving anytime anywhere soon
this queen over here on a3
it's not really involved into the game
everything that white has is completely
involved
already castled both the bishops eyeing
down on some very critical squares
so this would be a tough spot for black
even if black was able to find
the best line so as we come back uh mbl
did not fall for the trap but i think a
lot of people would how could you really
see what white has going on in that
threat so
instead we see hey mbl just says i'm
just going to continue to
gobble up material if you want to give
me a massive point advantage i will take
it so queen takes here on a2
rook over here to d1 queen up here to d5
queen to e3 and then queen takes here on
e5 and this is a pretty interesting game
to analyze overall because
if you look at it fabiano is down three
pawns and he doesn't have an immediate
threat now he does have an eventual
threat because as we've talked about
black does not have a lot of active
pieces he's been
mbl has been moving his queen around the
board uh
his king is exposed in the center of the
board
his knight here on b8 is not developed
his knight here on d7 was playing
defense but he's not controlling the
center of the board
neither of the rooks are involved into
the game so fabiano really showing that
hey i don't just have to be
up material i can use my position
and i can turn that into a much better
position
mvl on the other side has got to be
thinking i'm up three points in material
as long as i can just hold down the fort
for a while
i should be able to turn this into
a victory here and maintain my top spot
at
on the leaderboard fabiano pushes with
c3 here
bishop here to a c5 and then a massive
mistake from fabiano
i think he's getting a little too cute
he plays uh after bishop two g3 and the
queen comes he plays bishop here to
c4 and mvl says yeah if you just want to
keep giving me material
that's fine i'll go ahead and take it
and then we see bishop here 2d6 and i
just don't know if fabiano was expecting
a huge blunder
like bishop takes and then knight to d6
check and then
you know the queen is going to fall and
black just in a terrible
position i'm not sure exactly what he
thought mbl was going to do
really all nbl had to do was just take
right here on
d4 he's up so much material
then just start sacrificing material and
you should be in a pretty good spot here
like from this position
i find it hard to believe that nbl is
not going to have a very very good game
but instead he took 20 minutes and then
after bishop to d6 played the move
knight to f6 and i think this really
allowed fabiano back in the game here
he takes with his knight here on a c5
knight comes to
d5 attacking the queen queen comes up
here to e5
rook to g8 defending this pawn here on a
g7
knight takes the pawn up here on e6
and then after the pawn takes you can
see that the king is starting to get
pretty exposed here
and then we see the knight take on e6
and
really there's not a lot of safety in
front of this king here
for black so mbl definitely has to go
into
defense mode after he takes the pawn
here on c3 so
uh queen takes and then we see the
knight take here on
c3 and then it comes down to who can
execute in
the in game the best so knight to c7
attacking that exposed king king to f7
rook up here to d3 attacking the knight
knight comes back to
e4 attacking the bishop decides to go
into castle on the king side
with a check here on the king on f7
and then the knight takes here on a8
that comes back here to b6 and so if we
start to analyze these
these in games you can see that both
sides are now equal in
material a minor piece a knight or a
bishop and two pawns
is equal to that of a rook but really
when you get into it in game
the pieces together really matter a lot
so
bishops working together work extremely
well two rooks
are extremely powerful together they can
just block off
so many of the the rows and columns and
so
it's very difficult for for black to
have the advantage here
while white has two rooks on board
mvl now brings his rook over here to d8
then we see an exchange here on c8
bishop comes back here to a3
rook to c7 hook up here to f4 attacking
the knights here
bishop comes down to b2
that up here to e7 we do see an exchange
right here and this is exactly what
fabiano's looking to do here
is exchange off some of those minor
pieces make sure his opponent
did not have that bishop up here um he
just wants to get to a point where he
can really use the power of these two
rooks together
on nbl side he's got to put some
pressure with these two pass pawns over
here on
the queen side he can't just keep them
back here and leave these easy pickings
for fabiano to attack
he has to put some pressure on his
opponent favano pushes forward here with
h4 we see h5 to stop that push here
rook over here to g3 check
rook up here to g5 attacking this pawn
here
on h5 but also saying yeah this pawn's
pinned down so you can't actually take
it with your pawn
rook down here to c1 check king here to
h2
knight here to g6 so pretty good setup
for mvl here
then we see rook 2 f2 now what i think
is a pretty big mistake
is the night taking here on h4
because this kind of blows up the entire
thing the pawn
knight and pawn here are really stopping
white from getting behind enemy lines
and really blowing up
this queen side of the board here as
soon as this knight comes over here to
h4
that ship has sailed with rook takes
here
on h5 you just really don't want that to
happen here because as soon as you do
the knight's under attack
okay the knight comes back here to g6
but now rook to
h7 check after the king moves rook takes
here on
b7 and you can start to see things
slipping away here
for mvl we have knight to e5
decentralizing the night a little bit
that's fine
rook to a b6 check so yeah let's go
ahead and exchange right here
right now fabiano has the advantage but
it's a difficult one to turn
into a victory here one of the first
things you need to do is get your king
involved into the game it was over here
on h2
since black did have the
rook attacking it wanted to stay safe
but now that the rook is
off the board needs to really centralize
that key and get involved into the game
king comes back here to f7
rook to c2 attacking the knight knight
comes down here to a b4 and in this
position
uh fabiano probably took the longest he
did in the entire game
thinking about a move just trying to
figure out how he wanted to continue
a lot of people analyzing the game
fabiano
uh or we actually had magnus carlsen on
one of the the premier websites going
over analysis and they analyzed
this position specifically for a very
very long time fabiano eventually played
rook to d2 knight comes back here to
c6 king to f4 decentralizing a little
bit more as we talked about king 2
g6 that up here rook to these excuse me
attacking the knights
the pawn is going to fall and you can
start to see
that fabiano definitely has the upper
hand but
if you analyze this while it'll tell you
that white has the
advantage just from a pure material
standpoint since both sides have one
pawn and a rook is worth more than a
night
this is an extremely difficult end game
like
very very difficult you can see that the
king
and the knight are really just going to
be moving around
protecting each other and it's very
difficult to find an
opening for white and it's going to be a
very very long
end game it takes someone with a lot of
skill in the end game
luckily for fabiano he is
just that person now this game ended up
being around
six hours so it took an extremely long
time
as both players were trying to figure
out could anyone
actually break through obviously fabiano
the only possible person that could
break through here
but lots of back and forth a lot of
trying to figure out if there's just one
small advantage that once someone could
find in this position
and so they kept going over and over and
many times i really thought that they
were just going to extend hands fabiano
was just going to get frustrated and say
i don't think i can get a victory here
and i don't want to use up all of my
mental power in
the first game back after a year in this
tournament uh because i'm gonna need
that for
other games but he kept on going and
eventually
got to a point where he had a position
that he really
liked and part of that was getting his
king to
h5 with the knight over here on
the e-file this is a huge
piece of solving the the riddle here and
so
after the knight comes to d5 we see rook
2 f3 this is blocking off the knight
coming to both
e3 and f4 and this allows white to now
play the move
g4 this entire time probably
25 moves has all been setting up for
fabiano to push
forward with this pawn here on g4 when
he had his king over here on
the h file that's exactly what he did
mvl recognizing that there's not too
much that he can do
once uh fabiano has this setup and so
after 74 moves mbl decides to go ahead
and
resign so fabiano is now only a half
point out of first place he's now tied
with mdl they're both tied for a second
play so
really really good start to the
tournament or the the restart of the
tournament
for fabiano excited to see if he can
continue the run here
uh was fun to see him play magnus cross
in the world championship
a few years ago uh i'll be curious to
see if he gets another shot but thank
you guys so much for watching
i'm so pumped to have the candace
tournament back uh
and hopefully you guys are excited to
watch the coverage
over the next week and a half again i'll
have at least
one video up from each and every round
but thank you guys so much for watching
support in the channel
if you enjoyed the video in the coverage
if you wouldn't mind hitting that like
button definitely helps out quite a bit
and i'll see you guys
in the next video